[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du samsung galaxy à 6 et quelques jours
je vous ai fait un homme boxing pour
l'ouvrir prendre un petit peu comment
éviter ce qui arrive dans la boîte tout
ça tout ça tout ça tout ça et
aujourd'hui on va aller plus loin
aujourd'hui en faire un test complet on
va regarder ce samsung galaxy ace 6 cl
intéressant s'il est cool s'il répond
petit peu aux critères au cahier des
charges de smartphones moyenne gamme
plutôt côté entrée de gamme de moyenne
gamme faudra voir s'il intéressants ont
regardé par rapport aux différents
concurrents comment est ce qu'ils se
positionnent et au final est ce que ça
vaut le coup de l'acheter
oui ou non et pour voir tout ça on y va
revoilà la bête tout d'abord je tiens à
remercier mon partenariat afin de poing
comme qui me permet de tester ce produit
de vous dire ce que j'en pense merci à
fon qu'on va donc faire dans cette vidéo
ça regardait point par point on va leur
prendre dans les mains on va regarder on
va avoir un petit côté fiche technique
on va le décrire on va voir s'il est
intéressant si ce type de vous
intéresser
pour vous donner un avis objectif et
vous dire si ça vaut le coup de le
prendre ou non voilà le samsung galaxy
ace 6 voilà la jolie boîte dont sarah
déjà vu lors d'uen boxing donc on va
aller droit au but on va reprendre la
bête d'un point de vue purement
esthétique du point de vue du design moi
je trouve en tout cas du point de vue du
dos très similaire au j5 de 2017
là vous avez un dos en métal on n'a pas
un côté aspect plastique on sent tout
vraiment sens que c'est du métal par
contre au niveau du design avec la
plupart thiero la petite partie en bas
on a vraiment l'impression de retrouver
sur le j5 2017 alors la différence vous
avec le j5 ce que j 5
n'allez pas le petit capteur photo vous
avez votre flash qui était positionné
directement sur le côté mais d'un point
de vue global d'impôt du statique il lui
ressemble énormément du point de vue de
la face avant même qu'on parlait plutôt
maintenant au samsung galaxy à 8 pour
qu'une petite différence par rapport à 8
sur les côtés j'ai l'impression qu'ici
les bords sont un peu plus important que
sur le galaxy à 8 pas énormément à c'est
un tout petit peu mais il semble mais la
sorte on a vraiment des angles à 90
degrés pour trouver sans tous les côtés
alors que sur le à huit vous avez des
angles qui sont légèrement arrondi du
point de vue l'écran c'est la même chose
5,6 pouces super amoled écran infinitif
trouve que ceux à six il est à mi chemin
entre un gie 5j celle de 2017 et le a8
de 2018
autre différence par rapport à 8 vous
avez ici du micro usb sur l'a8 vous avez
de l'usb type sais c'est pas non plus un
produit qui vendu au même tarif le m8
coûte 499 euros et celui ci vous le
trouvez à 309 euros
règle générale le point fort de ce
mobile assez son écran infiniti on sait
que samsung phase du traitement des
écrans de super bonne qualité et ça une
fois de plus on va pas leur enlever
surtout dans cette gamme de prix vous
retrouver beaucoup d'écrans lcd là pour
que c'est plutôt pas mal
alors la résolution est forcément plus
basse que celle du n8 vous avez deux
révolutions 2480 par 720 pixels 16
millions de couleurs alors que sur le à
huit vous avez révolution de 2220 par
1080 pixels
côté performances la bête fonctionne
plutôt pas mal vous avez un processeur
exynos 7885 quitte à danser à 1,6
gigahertz 3 giga de ram bon sur le à
huit vous avez le même processeur c'est
un docte accord également la cadence un
peu plus élevé
c'est une 2,2 gigahertz 4 gigas de ram
pour une utilisation standard celui ci
en tout cas fait vraiment bien la faire
tourner plutôt pas mal
il a ses fûts lorsqu'on fait des petits
tourne plutôt pas mal bon on va pas se
mentir c'est pas non plus une usine à
gaz mais bon on peut faire quand même
pas mal de choses avec
et ça c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
alors bon j'ai essayé j'ai fait
plusieurs jeux j'avais pas mal de choses
une surchauffe pas ne reçoivent pas bon
je n'ai pas non plus pousser dans ses
retranchements on peut faire des tests
un petit peu plus sauvage pour secouer
davantage mon tout cas pour ce que j'en
ai c'est ça va il fonctionne plutôt pas
trop mal
du point de vue de l'ol s'il tourne sous
un android et 8.0 oreo qui fonctionne
plutôt bien niveau autonomie je suis pas
déçu moi avec une batterie de 3000
millions eur qui fonctionne plutôt bien
on peut le garder en veille plusieurs
jours on peut l'utiliser une journée
sans être déçu ça dépend bien évidemment
d'autres utilisations si vous allez
utiliser de façon intensive forcément il
va consommer davantage
la reconnaissance faciale fonctionne
bien et déverrouille très très
rapidement à se faire un test
hop je vous le mets là lemattre ans en
face aucune correspondance pour le coup
ça marche pas hop je l'éteins jeu le
positionne ici je mets ma tronche en
face et voilà qui déverrouille le
capteur d'empreintes digitales aussi au
dos fonctionne plutôt bien je le prends
hop
j'appuie hop ça déverrouille rapidement
bon ça fonctionne on n'a rien à lui
reprocher de ce côté là côté photo vidéo
j'ai rien à lui reprocher vous avez
essayé une caméra de 16 mégapixels avec
une ouverture de f
1.7 ici un autre 16 mégapixels et
l'ouverture de f1 points 9
lorsque vous allez chuté dans des
conditions de basse luminosité ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal
alors on n'en parle pas du s9 s9 plus
qui la déchire tout à h tout sur la
faible luminosité sur la photo et de la
vidéo
mais en règle générale si vous avez un
samsung c'est quand même assez récent il
ya deux trois ans pour les photos en
faible luminosité n'est pas déçu que
vous avez plusieurs modes vous avez une
mode automatique mode trop panorama
rafale le hdr nuit sport sont éprises ça
directement sur la caméra arrière alors
si vous souhaitiez sur la caméra avant
vous avez le mode celle ficelles fille
panoramas sont éprises celle-ci panorama
paris faire dans une espèce de panoramas
de votre selphy bon sénat globalement
assez peu d'intérêt
mais bon why not je ne sais pas si c'est
vraiment très intéressant de le faire
alors il ya une grosse différence par
rapport au galaxy à huit c'est la
stabilisation là dessus on n'avait pas
de stabilisation
ce qui fait que si vous bouger un petit
peu si vous avez un peu la tremblote
tout de suite un peu le bazar ce qui moi
et mon cas donc tout de suite vous allez
vous retrouver avec une image un rendu
qui sera pas terrible terrible on s'en
va l'essayer très très rapidement à
l'extérieur du poids de vidéo pour
filmer
jusqu'en 1080p 1920 par 1080 la taille
de l'image 16 mégapixels enquête
thierville mégapixels 2007 bon ça je
vous fasse un petit peu vous restez là
dessus assure le syndicat pixels ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal pour la
photographie il ya un mode qui rigolo
c'est le mode sont éprises appuyer la
samoa se risque à 9 secondes d'audio
directement en prenant une seule photo
on y va hop je prends ma photo l'horloge
par contre en 9 secondes pour vous dire
à quel point je suis content d'être avec
vous il ya quel point je connais de vous
présenter ce smartphone le samsung
galaxy à 6 que je trouve plutôt pas mal
c'est pas un truc extraordinaire mais
vous pouvez envoyer des photos à vos
amis avec de la voix intègre est
pourquoi pas après vous retrouverez bien
évidemment bixby vision vous avez
toujours vos fameuses autocollants
directement là pour pouvoir avoir une
tête de chat de chiens de tout ce que
vous voulez vous pouvez avoir des
watermark votre vie n'y est ici qui
apparaîtra sur toutes vos photos et
surtout vos souvenirs samsung galaxy
caméra bon pour faire la pub c'est
plutôt pas mal
vous avez effectivement tout ça il ya
des petits messages pouvaient rajouter
aussi un division qui est là pour vous
aider un petit peu a repéré des
bouteilles avoir des informations sur un
plat c'est ça c'est l'intelligence
artificielle de san suu kyi va être
amené à développer de plus en plus alors
au niveau de la caméra vous avez un
autofocus qui normalement marche pas
trop mal vous même vous montrer des
fleurs complètement crevé ça va changer
montre toujours des jolies choses
la joueuse bien samsung galaxy caméra la
hauteur marque énormément vous n'êtes
pas obligé de la m mais ça nous promet
un petit peu de bien différencier par
rapport au plan que je vais faire de
façon classique d'un autofocus se fait
pas directement font que j'appuie sur
une touche pipi dessus d'ayer j'ai
récupéré je suis dessus mais voyez la
stabilisation est les pages et là je le
tiens à une main ça tremble ça bouge un
petit peu c'est un petit peu dommage
mais voilà maintenant sur la caméra
avant à l'europe
attention je la tiens une manne en
allemand ça va bouger un petit peu là
c'est l'emballage de terre directement
la main donc pour voir un petit peu la
stab je regarde avec vous voyez la
stabilisation s'est pas tarie terrien
n'a pas donc de toutes façons on va se
poser la question de la star n'a pas sa
bouche de tous les côtés ça donne un
petit peu la gerbe donc lâché retour
dans mon studio je suis dans une pièce
qui complètement dans le noir alors j'ai
juste ici des volets fermés donc on se
rend pas compte mais y'a bon
effectivement dehors il fait jour mais
si
complètement sombre et je trouve que
malgré tout le rendu est pas
complètement complètement dégueulasse
alors effectivement c'est très très très
son envoi derrière qui réajuste la
lumière ici du post mais sinon il fait
complètement noir et je trouve que dans
l'absolu lâché sur les caméras de saïfi
fonctionne plutôt pas mal alors
maintenant je vais remettre une petite
lumière vous allez voir d'un coup on a
changé ça va éprouver attention les a321
bîmes
or ça fait mal voilà comme surtout les
samsung le général je trouve que les
caméras sont plutôt pas mal par faible
luminosité ça marche on est sur le cas
d'un arrière f
1.7 du coup on 4 quand même suffisamment
de lumière
on n'est pas sur une ouverture variable
qu'on peut avoir sur les 9,9 plus ménard
on va très clairement ça fonctionne ça
fait la paire et on est sur un
smartphone qui coûte à peine 300 euros
c'était quelques fautes poche pour que
dans l'ensemble le résultat est quand
même plutôt pas mal les rendus sont
intéressants le détail et pas mal
l'autofocus fonctionne plutôt pas mal je
n'ai pas trouvé tout de suite hyper
hyper réactif mais dans l'absolu voyez
là par exemple j'ai voulu prendre une
abeille qui était la bombe un manque de
bol je les payais puis après elle s'est
barrée
il faut que dans l'absolu ça
fonctionnait quand même bon voilà
c'était pas trop mal
la up on voit très clairement que le
point est fait derrière il passé là mais
sinon ça marche quand même plutôt pas
mal avec la si vous avez la possibilité
d'avoir une double carte sim d'avoir une
extension en carte microsd en plus vous
avez des bus tous 4.2 ici alors que dans
l'es8 vous avez dit bluetooth 5.0 vous
avez du nfc vous avez une prise jack et
par contre j'ai trouvé absolument aucune
information sur une probable
hypothétique peut-être ou pas du tout
certification ifs et 68 vous êtes tout
une gestion aussi de vos fichiers de
sauvegarde directement l'intérêt n'en
marquons à 32 giga on a déjà onze giga
d'utiliser sur les 32 vous pouvez
rajouter une carte micro sd en plus et
après vous pouvez faire de la synchro
dans le cloud avec samsung claude drive
google drive est un drive vous avez bien
évidemment accès aux playlists or là je
vous apprends rien pour avoir accès au
catalogue complet de google à toutes les
applications mais vous avez aussi accès
directement aux galaxies ap
avec toutes les applications qui sont
sélectionnés par samsung et dans
l'absolu ce galaxy à 6 comment ils se
positionnent par rapport à la
concurrence ça c'est une vraie bonne
question à se poser
nous comptons en projet d'acheter un
smartphone comme celui-là parce que le à
six coups de 309 euros
et si vous regardez le samsung galaxy a
huit qui coûte quand même 499 euros on a
quasiment 200 euros d'écart entre deux
pros
milieu de gamme alors celui ci lui est
si c'est le produit d'entrée du milieu
de gamme alors que je dirais plutôt que
c'est le produit haut de gamme du milieu
de garde qui va un petit peu flirté avec
les produits haut de gamme sans pour
autant y être
et si vous voulez payer un petit peu
moins cher dans l'entré deux guerres
vous avez le j5 et le 17/02/2010 est
qu'ils sont si banal si vous regardez un
peu tout ça c'est qu'effectivement vous
voulez acheter un produit de samsung
pour un budget autour des 300 euros
pour moi le lcif l affaire si vous avez
un petit peu plus de budget vous serez
quand même beaucoup plus gâtés avec 1,8
si vous regardez haut niveau la
concurrence doivent aussi le aux
nordistes à un tarif de 399 euros ça
pour moi c'est un smartphone qui se
positionne entre le 6 et le à 8 en
termes de budget vous avez quand même
kirin 970 à l'intérieur un écran de 5 8
pouces par contre d'un écran lcd et pour
le coup le point un petit peu négatif
c'est que la mémoire n'est pas
extensible
si vous souhaitez avoir un smartphone
qui quasiment dans le même budget vous
avez le 8 cordes view de pro que je
teste également en ce moment là pour que
vous devrez d'écrans plus grands 6
pouces lcd est un snapdragon 450 donc un
peu moins de puissance par rapport à ce
que vous allez là dedans alors pendant
qu'il parlait de puissance a pas une
bête de compet mais bon un petit peu en
demi-teinte par rapport à ce produit à
voir on va faire un comparatif est un
test très très très prochainement on va
comparer le a6 et du de pro donc restez
connectés après ce que deux pros et d
une batterie de 3000 bilan terreur
exactement comme celui là et il a
surtout une stabilisation logiciel
lorsque vous allez faire de la vidéo ça
c'est quand même un point positif alors
c'est pas non plus une stabilisation du
fou furieux marche pas mal alors au
final ce samsung galaxy ace 6 est ce que
ça vaut le coup de l'acheter si je
devais acheter un smartphone et si
j'avais un budget aux alentours des 300
euros du prune faire une brèche pour le
trouve intéressant pourquoi déjà parce
que l'écran l'écran je suis séduite par
l'écran super amoled l'écran infiniti
faisait toujours de très très très bonne
qualité
alors la résolution c'est à la même
résolution ou pour avoir sur un an 8
donc le eg8 et plus haut de gamme est
plus intéressant pour avoir vraiment une
meilleure définition une meilleure
résolution sur vos smartphones mais pour
un budget autour des 300 euros pas non
plus lui demander la lune est pas
attendre des exploits extraordinaires
malgré tout c'est un bon smartphone je
suis plus séduits par l'écran par le
design le design c'est un petit peu un
goût de revenez-y du j5 et du jce est
malgré tout il est efficace design est
pas top top design n'est pas
complètement dingos malgré tout
et plutôt bien la qualité photo et vidéo
est au rendez vous donc on a rien à lui
reprocher et je vous dis une fois de
plus pour un budget 300 euros ça
fonctionne d'ailleurs vous dites moi si
vous êtes intéressé dit moi si vous
pensez acheter ce produit et pour tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas se positionner
dessus dites moi si vous avez un samsung
galaxy à 8,2 cette année
si vous l'avez testé si vous êtes
satisfait oui non et qu'est ce que vous
pensez de celui là si vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter
vous remarquez tout sens comme ça parce
que ça pourra aider tous ceux et toutes
celles qui souhaitent acheter un
smartphone dans un budget aux alentours
des 300 euros on remarque tout ça en
discute et on laisser un petit peu de
s'entraîner voit la solidarité avec ceux
qui veulent acheter les smartphones
merci à vous tous que d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo comme d'habitude vous invite
à laisser des jolies pousse à vous
abonner à ce que vous allez voir
y'a plein de son prix ce qui arrive ya
plein de nouveaux tests des comparatifs
plein d'infos que ce sont des
smartphones ce sont d'autres choses là
monde connecté on peut imaginer plein
plein de trucs donc on reste connectés
et vous allez voir les 100 prix sont
très nombreux et ce d'autant plus que je
travaille activement message idée déjà
dit son nouveau format pour le mois de
septembre
et croyez moi j'y travaille corps et âme
j'y passe tout mon temps toutes mes
heures tout mais lui tous les jours le
seul moment où travaillent pas dessus
ces moments peuvent vidéo donc voilà
bonjour merci a bientot son message je
vous embrasse
[Musique]